Welcome to our next chapter, Chapter 5 Life in the Greenhouse here on Earth, where we'll
also learn about photosynthesis and global climate change.
Make sure you check out our learning outcomes and recognize them as we come to them throughout
our lessons and readings.
Here's a question.
Most scientists disagree that global climate change is occurring.
Well, the answer to that one is a big false.
In late 2015, high-level representatives of governments of nearly all the Earth's nations
met in Paris for a historic dialogue.
The end result was an agreement signed on December 12 in 2015 to combat global warming.
The 195 signatory countries agreed to eliminate human-derived greenhouse gas emissions by 2050.
As the agreement is being implemented, developing countries are to receive financial assistance
to help cut emissions.
And aid will be given to those nations that lack the resources to mitigate the negative
effects of climate change.
In dozens of cities throughout the world, hundreds of thousands of activists and ordinary
citizens participated in peaceful and dramatic marches in the days leading up to the conference.
The size of these rallies may have given world leaders the confidence to act.
Indeed, many of these leaders were exhilarated by the hard-won final product.
This is truly a historic moment, said Ban Kimun, the United Nations Secretary-General.
For the first time, we've truly a universal agreement on climate change, one of the most
crucial problems on Earth.
Many environmental activists were more circumspect, noting that the accord did not specify any
particular actions to combat the growing threat of climate change.
Secretary-General Ban Kimun's description of climate change as one of Earth's most crucial
problems is not an exaggeration.
But what could sound like a small increase, the 1 degree Celsius temperature rise recorded
since the beginning of the Industrial Revolution, dramatic climate shifts have already occurred.
Mountain glaciers and polar ice caps are disappearing.
While sea levels rise, storms have become more severe and destructive, and insects carrying
disease have changed their distribution patterns.
This has threatened human populations.
Scientists say that anything above a 2 degree Celsius, which is 3.6 degrees Fahrenheit, increase
over the historical average will doom us to a future of even more severe consequences.
These consequences include even more severe storms, and resulting widespread food and
water shortages.
Given what scientists say about the severity of the crisis and the consequences of inaction,
it may be crucial for humanity's survival and well-being that we band together to address
climate change.
The Paris Accord, although far from perfect, is an important step in that process.
But what can science tell us about how we got in this predicament in the first place?
And perhaps more important, what can we do about it now?
Global warming is the progressive increase of Earth's average temperature that's been
occurring over the past century.
There's little debate among scientists and government-appointed panels about the nature
and cause of global warming.
And global warming is contributing to global climate change.
The local changes in average temperature, precipitation and sea level relative to historical
conditions that are occurring in locations all over the planet.
Scientists who publish and peer reviewed journals and respected scientific panels and societies
such as the Intergovernmental Panel on Climate Control, otherwise known as the IPCC, the
National Academy of Sciences, and the American Association for the Advancement of Science
the AAAS all agree that the average temperature on Earth is increasing and that most of the
global warming observed in the past century is attributable to human activities.
Again, global climate change is the local changes in average climate conditions, including
temperature, precipitation and sea level, and this is again relative to historic conditions.
Global Earth's climate does fluctuate over time due to changes in Earth's orbit and solar
output.
Human-caused or anthropogenic global warming has dramatically increased the rate of change.
Again, it's about here the rate of change, so much so it might be difficult for humans
to even adjust.
Economic global warming is caused by recent increases in the concentration of particular
gases called greenhouse gases in the atmosphere.
These include water vapor, carbon dioxide or CO2, methane known as CH4, and ozone or O3.
The accumulation of many of the greenhouse gases is a direct result of coal, oil, and
natural gas combustion.
The most abundant gas emitted by the combustion of fossil fuels is carbon dioxide, so for
this reason carbon dioxide is considered the most important greenhouse gas to control.
Much atmospheric gas is a greenhouse gas, well from our previous slides, we've learned
that it's all three of these methane, water vapor and carbon dioxide with CO2 being the
number one to control.
The presence of carbon dioxide and all the other greenhouse gases in the atmosphere leads
to a phenomenon called the greenhouse effect.
These gases being in our atmosphere trap the energy that comes to earth from our very
own sun.
The sun warms the earth's surface, that heat bounces back up, radiates outward, but all
of it doesn't get to escape back into space, so some of it's reflected back down to earth
by the greenhouse gases.
So we could say the greenhouse gases we have here on earth act like a sort of a atmospheric
blanket, just like you sleeping under a blanket, your body heat warms the blanket and traps
the heat, so that blanket keeps you warm.
As we get more greenhouse gases accumulating in the atmosphere, it's like having a thicker
blanket, more heat is retained and re-radiated, just like a warmer temperature under a blanket
that you might use yourself.
Well, what if I told you that the greenhouse effect is good for life here on earth?
Well, that actually is true, it's not in itself a dangerous phenomenon, it's necessary for
humans and all other living organisms here on earth.
If earth's atmosphere did not have some greenhouse gases, too much heat would be lost to space,
and then the earth would be too cold to support life.
The danger imposed by anthropogenic global warming is in the speed of temperature increase,
and thus the changes in weather patterns and sea levels that exceed the ability of many
living organisms to adapt.
So what might this mean for our very own species?
Well remember we have a lot of water here on earth, and bodies of water absorb energy
and help maintain stable temperatures here on earth.
You'll remember with the hydrogen bonds that water has between the water molecules, it
makes water heat up slowly and resist temperature changes.
This is actually good for life on earth because we don't like drastic temperature changes.
Heat is the total amount of energy associated with the movement of atoms and molecules,
and temperature measures the intensity of heat or how fast the molecules are moving.
Large volumes contain more heat due to greater totals of molecular movements.
Again the formation of hydrogen bonds between neighboring molecules of water makes it more
cohesive than other liquids, in other words water molecules tend to stick together.
These same hydrogen bonds also make water resistant to temperature changes.
Even when a large amount of heat is added, that phenomenon occurs because when water
is heated the energy first must disrupt the hydrogen bonds.
Only after enough of the hydrogen bonds have been broken can heat cause individual water
molecules to move faster, thus increasing their temperature.
When water cools, the hydrogen bonds reform between adjacent water molecules.
This releases heat into the atmosphere.
A body of water can store a large amount of heat from its surroundings while experiencing
only a small increase in temperature and vice versa.
Water's heat, absorbing capacity, has important effects on our Earth's climate.
And after all we have a lot of water on Earth with all of our oceans and lakes and all that
water helps to keep temperatures moderate by absorbing huge amounts of heat radiated
by the sun and then releasing that heat during less sunnier times.
This warms the air and prevents large temperature swings.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
As the temperature continues to rise, individual water molecules can move fast enough to break
free of all hydrogen bonds and then rise up into the air as water vapor.
And that's the basis for our water cycle here on Earth.
Water moves from land, oceans, and lakes to clouds, and then back to the Earth's surfaces
again, as we see in this diagram here.
As the amount of heat trapped near our Earth's surface has increased, well, the water cycle
has changed.
It's sped up.
The intensification of the cycle leads to more extremes on both ends of the climate spectrum.
In other words, wet places are getting wetter and dry places are getting drier.
The carbon dioxide increase driving this change comes from many different sources.
First I'll ask this question, "How does your body heat compare to the cool lake where
you swim?"
Well the answer is B. Remember that heat is the total amount of energy associated with
the movement of atoms and molecules, while a lake contains more heat because it has a
greater volume of molecular movement than just your body.
To help us understand a little bit more about our greenhouse gases like carbon dioxide, let's
take a look at the flow of carbon on Earth.
The flow of carbon on Earth is called the carbon cycle.
Remember that the atoms that make up living organisms primarily contain a lot of carbon.
That's why we call life here on Earth carbon based life or organic life.
Carbon can also be found in the atmosphere as carbon dioxide, it can also be found absorbed
in the water, lakes and our oceans and other bodies of water and even in rocks as well.
And most of the carbon dioxide in our atmosphere is actually not from natural processes, it
comes from the combustion of fossil fuels, which as you can see when we go back to the
this picture is shown here with industry emitting carbon dioxide into the atmosphere.
It's also emitted into the atmosphere from Earth through volcanoes as well.
As part of the carbon cycle, carbon dioxide is absorbed by plants and algae and some bacteria
who are able to perform photosynthesis.
They take in the carbon dioxide and they convert it to sugars or carbohydrates with the use
of sunlight energy.
And then this, the sugars created by photosynthesis are the source of cellular energy
for most organisms here on Earth.
That carbon is eventually then released by the organisms that consume the carbohydrates
by, well, breathing for one thing when you breathe out carbon dioxide that goes back
into the atmosphere.
But you can also release carbon back to Earth when you die as well and decomposers break
down the carbohydrates in your body and other molecules and then release that back to Earth.
There are some unconsumed carbohydrates that have been buried for millennia and those
are called fossil fuels.
These are highly concentrated energy sources, lots of carbon and hydrogen and bonds with
their potential energy in those bonds, just waiting there for us to dig them out and burn
them as our fuel.
These were produced from unconsumed carbohydrates of ancient buried organisms.
They're transformed by heat and pressure.
Examples include petroleum, coal, and natural gas.
Humans now use fossil fuels, especially since the industrial revolution to power homes, vehicles,
and businesses.
This releases that stored carbon that's been there for millions of years and then, unfortunately,
contributes to the accumulation of atmospheric carbon dioxide.
Human use of fossil fuels is having a measurable effect.
Increases in carbon dioxide in the atmosphere are well documented by direct measurements
over the past 50 years.
In addition, scientists can analyze fossil air.
Can you believe it?
Fossilized air.
But yeah, it's been trapped within ancient ice sheets and then we can use that to determine
carbon dioxide over longer time spans.
Such measurement is possible because snow falling on an ice sheet traps the air as snow accumulates
underlying snow is compressed into ice and the trapped air becomes tiny, ice encased
air bubbles.
It gives us a way to look back into history and see what the earth's atmosphere was like
at the time those air bubbles were trapped.
These are called ice cores.
From these, we were able to see that current carbon dioxide levels are the highest level
in over 400,000 years and we know temperature and carbon dioxide levels are correlated.
First, I want to go back to this graph as well as we can see the average concentration
of carbon dioxide steadily increasing over time.
Here, carbon dioxide concentration is measured in parts per million.
And this graph is only from 1960 to 2017.
Imagine what the graph would look like over the last 400,000 years.
But this is well documented actual data and evidence.
Again, temperature and carbon dioxide levels are correlated and here we can see that.
Here we see records of temperature and atmospheric carbon dioxide concentration from Antarctic
ice cores.
This data indicates that increases in carbon dioxide levels are correlated with higher
temperatures.
So, when carbon dioxide levels and the atmosphere are high, well, take a look at what happens
to the temperature.
The temperature also goes up.
Take a look at the present one right here.
Carbon dioxide concentration is way up here and what's going to happen to our temperature.
If we look in the past, look at the blue line.
This is what's happened every time our carbon dioxide levels have gotten high.
There's a video embedded into this slide show called the carbon cycle.
If you're unable to play it over your slide show, you can also click on this YouTube video
here or just do a search on YouTube for carbon cycle and there's a plethora of videos available.
Modern plants and certain microorganisms do as their ancient predecessors did, they absorb
carbon dioxide from the atmosphere and convert it to carbohydrates.
Is it possible that we could depend on these modern organisms to reduce the amount of greenhouse
gases released by fossil fuel burning and thus the threat posed by global climate change?
Well, photosynthesis is the process that traps light energy from the sun and uses it to convert
carbon dioxide and water into sugars or carbohydrates.
In other words, photosynthesis transforms solar energy into the chemical energy required
by all living things here on Earth.
In the picture below, we see a chloroplasts, which is an organelle that all photosynthetic
organisms have in order to do these reactions.
Plants, some protists like algae and some bacteria like cyanobacteria are able to do this.
A chloroplasts is like an envelope, it has an inner and outer membrane to enclose it.
Some other parts are the stroma, which is the fluid-filled compartment.
This holds a lot of enzymes or proteins for doing the process of photosynthesis.
It's like a thick fluid area.
Then there's these little stacks of disks called the phylicoids.
These are little structures that have membranes of their own that are stacked in piles and
again increase the surface area for areas to do photosynthesis reactions.
These phylicoids also hold chlorophyll, which is different pigment molecules.
There's more than one type of chlorophyll, but there are different pigment molecules
made of protein.
They cover the surface of the phylicoid disk and they absorb light energy from the sun.
That's their job.
Some of them are more made to absorb the electromagnetic spectrum parts that are purple
and blue that we would see as visible light.
Others, red and oranges, but you'll notice that most of these photosynthetic organisms
are green and that's because their chlorophyll reflects back the green light.
That's because they're not using as much of the green light as they are the purple,
blues, oranges and reds.
This is why plants are green.
They reflect the visible light that they're not using and it turns out that they're just
not really using much of the greens and yellows.
Here's the equation for the process of photosynthesis.
We take carbon dioxide from the atmosphere also some water and light energy from the sun.
From that, reactions occur which make glucose, sugar, carbohydrate that feeds the world and
then oxygen which, hey, we kind of like oxygen too because we need to breathe that.
The chemical equation that's balanced is listed here and it occurs in two steps in different
areas of the chloroplasts.
The light reactions which occur in the phylicoids in the chlorophyll laden areas and then the
light independent reactions or sometimes also known as the Calvin cycle which occurs in
the stroma which is the liquid portion of the chloroplasts.
So here's a big picture of chloroplasts.
The light reactions occur here in the phylicoids where we have plenty of chlorophyll absorbing
sunlight and then dark reactions where the sugar is actually made here in the stroma.
In the light reactions sunlight actually excites chlorophyll, it excites the electrons in chlorophyll
molecules.
We've talked about in our last chapter how important electrons are, how they have potential
energy and when they move that changes to kinetic energy.
Well it's kind of the same idea here is that sunlight hits chlorophyll and it bounces up
electrons.
Then we have some receivers that grab onto those electrons as well.
Remember electrons also like to travel with their hydrogen so we have again kind of the
taxi cab that grabs onto them, the NAD, this time it's pH, for cell respiration it was
just NADH but in photosynthesis their molecule is NADPH.
They grab that extra H on the end there.
The light reactions are also thing to generate some ATP and they're going to produce some
oxygen as well.
The light reactions use water, that's why you need to water your plants.
They actually split water and they take the hydrogens which contain their wonderful electrons
and then they use those electrons to move them along enzymes just kind of like cell respiration
here.
When the electrons move along these enzymes it pumps hydrogen down here into the middle
of the filacoid.
Now we get that concentration gradient difference where hydrogen moves to an area and then moves
down again ATP synthase which is strategically placed so that these hydrogens move down it
and spin it and so some ATP is made also from photosynthesis.
Most people don't know that but it is but the electrons move forward and I won't get
into all the details here.
The electrons move forward with their hydrogens through their little taxi cab and are delivered
to the stroma out here where the calvin cycle or light independent reactions occur.
So this part is really similar to cell respiration in that we're trying to gather electrons with
their H's of course, they travel as an H and the taxi cab molecule brings it to this last
reaction here, the light independent reactions where we're going to use again those hydrogens
with their electron to generate sugar this time.
But in doing so with some of the other things going on here we are able to generate some
ATP as well.
Which molecule is produced during the light reactions of photosynthesis?
Well that is oxygen and if I go back here oxygen is produced when plants split water.
When the H's and electrons are taken from the water then we have oxygen left over as
a byproduct so the plant breathes that out.
Which molecule is the final product of the light independent reactions?
Well we haven't talked about that yet but I hope from the equations that I showed you
that you know that it is letter A that it's the sugar glucose.
There's some other molecules involved listed here that we'll talk about a little bit.
So the light independent reactions also known as the Kelvin cycle are a series of reactions
that occur in the liquid portion of the chloroplast called the stroma.
Their job is to use those H's that were gathered from the light reactions and even the ATP that
was generated and then produce sugar.
The light independent reactions or Kelvin cycle begins with RUBP.
This is the molecule that's coming off of the cycle so the job is that this enzyme here
called rubisco, ribulose, biphosphate, carboxylase oxygenase you can tell it's an enzyme there
with all the ASE endings but this enzyme grabs carbon dioxide out of the air and then joins
it with RUBP which is coming off of the Kelvin cycle and makes a six carbon molecule which
then a series of reactions breaks it into two three carbon molecules.
As we can see here here we see rubisco the enzyme grabbing RUBP coming off of the cycle
that's the leftovers from the last turn of the cycle also grabbing carbon dioxide out
of the air joining them together and making a product that eventually results in what's
called G3P this is kind of the precursor of glucose.
We don't actually end up with C6H1206 glucose right away it's going to take a little bit
for the plant to actually build that but G3P is a three carbon molecule that can be used
to make glucose eventually and then the plant will be able to store that glucose as usually
starch in its big storage vacuole that we know that plant cells have.
Again there is a photosynthesis animation embedded into this PowerPoint and if it doesn't work
just go to YouTube and do a search for photosynthesis animation and you'll be able to find all
kinds of videos that will pop up so we've established that in order to do this wonderful
process of photosynthesis plants need carbon dioxide to do that as well as water and other
things as well so how do plants allow carbon dioxide into their leaves leaves are like
big solar panels attracting sunlight well within the leaves are these little openings
called stomata and if you had a microscope and took a thin peel of a leaf you'd be able
to see stomata and they look like this they look like little eyeballs looking at you actually
and they can open and close so if they want to close to conserve water or not let air in
they can do that or they can open up wide and let lots of carbon dioxide into the leaf
but then also when they are open they will lose water as well these cells that are kind
of banana shaped around this the stomata are called guard cells and they help regulate
the stomata openings.
Transpiration is the movement of water through the stomata again when the stomata are open
like we see here they're letting carbon dioxide in but they're losing water in the process
in a tropical plant that's really not a problem but in a desert plant that might be a problem
we'll talk about that when the stomata are closed like we see in the bottom picture water
can be conserved but getting carbon dioxide in then becomes a problem so higher temperatures
can lower the rate of photosynthesis because a plant doesn't want to leave its stomata
open and then risk loss of all that water.
What structures and land plants allow carbon dioxide to enter and oxygen gas to be released
well as well as water well that would be letter B the stomata.
So back to that problem here where plants have their stomata open and then well that
lets in a lot of carbon dioxide so that's good for making sugar through photosynthesis
but it also risks the loss of water.
Again tropical plants not a problem where there's plenty of moisture but in a desert
that could be a huge problem.
Well there's a few reasons that plants have evolved other mechanisms and the loss of water
through the stomata is one of them.
Another reason that plants have evolved another type of mechanism for photosynthesis is due
to a process called photorespiration and photorespiration counteracts photosynthesis.
You see rubisco evolved a long time ago when there really wasn't a lot of oxygen on earth
but it turns out that besides grabbing carbon dioxide out of the air rubisco also sometimes
accidentally grabs oxygen and that's not good.
We want our photosynthetic enzyme rubisco we want that to grab carbon dioxide so that
we can be very efficient and make sugar carbohydrates but if rubisco grabs oxygen and then joins
it to the RUBP we make an acid it's called glycolate that really is not going to be useful
to the plant.
In fact it makes an acid that must be destroyed it creates more work for the plant and the
plant won't make sugar and it won't make ATP and will release carbon dioxide instead
of oxygen.
It's kind of like in the picture below where here rubisco is supposed to be with CO2 but
well once in a while it is good at grabbing oxygen as well so again that's called photorespiration
so it just shows us that our enzyme rubisco is not perfect though we wish it was but it
is not perfect so it's another reason why plants have evolved another way to do photosynthesis
to avoid some of these problems again one of the problems to avoid is loss of water through
the stomata and another problem is to avoid having rubisco grab the wrong molecule oxygen.
The type of photosynthesis that we've been talking about is called C3 photosynthesis where
that whole process actually resulted in making a three carbon molecule that eventually we
turn to sugar or the plant turns to sugar.
They are strictly only using bad enzyme rubisco so we know once in a while rubisco does grab
oxygen by accident so photorespiration may occur they are able to conserve water when
hot by closing their stomata soybeans are a good example of C3 plants.
As the earth warms it's possible that the abundance of C3 plants may decline as a result
of the increased burden of photorespiration in C4 plants they're able to avoid that problem
of photorespiration by using a different enzyme all together initially to grab carbon dioxide
out of the air it's called PEP carboxylase it's used to grab carbon dioxide out of the
air it's very good at it and then it passes it on eventually then to rubisco who's a little
deeper within the plant and then photosynthesis occurs as normal but it produces a four carbon
sugar instead of a three carbon sugar so we say C4 plants have additional pathways to concentrate
carbon dioxide to produce their four carbon sugars mostly grasses are C4 plants as the
earth warms it's possible that the abundance of C4 plants might increase and again C4 plants
are mostly grasses whereas most trees are the C3 plants because net rates of photosynthesis
in grasslands as measured by grams of carbon dioxide removed from the atmosphere per acre
per year are 30% to 60% less than the rates of forests the replacement of trees with grasses
significantly decreases the rate of removal of carbon dioxide from the atmosphere corn
is also a C4 plant besides grasses a third type of plant and third type of photosynthesis
called cam photosynthesis these plants typically live in drier areas and are trying to avoid
that problem of losing water through their stomata so to combat that they close their
stomata during the day and then they open the stomata at night so while the stomata
are open at night they allow carbon dioxide in and then they store it as an organic acid
and then once the sun comes out for the day the stomata close up and then those organic
acids that have the carbon dioxide stored within them are broken down and then used
for photosynthesis during the day again jade is an example of a cam plant so what type
of plants open their stomata only at night well that would be the cam plants they open
their stomata night and let the carbon dioxide in and conserve water that way but photosynthesis
still requires light so they still do photosynthesis during the day it's just that they
have to collect their carbon dioxide at night again as earth warms up amount or abundance
of cam plants will probably increase so again as earth warms up we have c4 plants and possibly
even cam plants outperforming the c3 plants and as we've already established c3 plants
like trees actually take more carbon dioxide out of the air then do the c4 plants so as
the c4 plants outperform the c3 plants deforestation the loss of trees can happen naturally in
a warming earth but it's already happening at higher the natural rates thanks to human
activities deforestation occurs when forests are cleared for logging farming and over ever
expanding human settlements it contributes directly to the increase in carbon dioxide
within the atmosphere current estimates are that up to 25% of the carbon dioxide introduced
into the atmosphere originates from the cutting and burning of forests in just the tropics
alone clearly one effective way to reduce global warming is to reduce deforestation and
promote photosynthesis by planting trees or c3 plants through reforestation projects
in the worst case rising temperatures due to global warming will cause vegetative land
to become desert completely eliminating photosynthesis in certain areas conversely warming temperatures
will expose more snow and ice covered regions permitting additional photosynthesis in such
regions as that unfortunately enhanced carbon dioxide uptake is likely to be offset by carbon
dioxide released from the more rapid decay of carbohydrates in the soil in these formerly
frozen regions loss of ice and snow will also lead to increased heat gain of earth surface
as formerly reflective surfaces become darker and more absorbent of light energy as we've
seen there's no guarantee that increased photosynthesis will soak up much of the excess carbon dioxide
released by fossil fuel combustion in fact the overall rate of photosynthesis might even
decline on a warmer planet so how can we slow this problem of global climate change anthropogenic
climate change has resulted in droughts in some areas and torrential rains and others
climate change will cause the extinction of animals and plants that have narrow temperature
requirements climate change has already contributed to the spread of infectious diseases and dangerous
pests that were once once limited to just the tropical environments by temperature alone
such as certain mosquitoes that could only live in tropical environments a lot of these
mosquitoes also carry certain diseases and you are only limited to catching them if you
lived in a tropical environment but if the earth warms their territory will expand in
fact it's already happening this particular mosquito we see here they're beginning to
move into geographical areas where they were once excluded another problem with the increasing
rate of carbon dioxide absorbed by the ocean is causing the ocean to get more acidic or
acidify or acidification this is damaging and killing coral reefs and threatening algae
in the open ocean and the organisms that depend on them remember algae are organisms that
can do photosynthesis but they're being threatened now because of the excess carbon dioxide so
clearly excess carbon dioxide in the atmosphere is already imposing a cost on people which
category do you think accounts for most of the carbon dioxide emissions for a country
well it's industry United States has a disproportionate impact on the rate of carbon dioxide emissions
into the atmosphere the United States is home to only four percent of the world population
but the United States produces close to twenty five percent of the carbon dioxide emitted
by fossil fuel burning in fact the average US household is responsible for 50,000 kilograms
of annual carbon dioxide emissions the emissions rate of carbon dioxide is known as your carbon
footprint for an average American it's twice that of a Japanese citizen or a German individual
three times that of the global average four times that of someone from Sweden and 20 times
that of the average Indian most of the emissions for an individual country come from industry
followed by transportation and then by commercial residential and agricultural admissions all
of us can work to reduce our personal contribution to global warming by decreasing residential
and transportation emissions most residential emissions are from energy used to heat in cool
homes and to power electrical appliances transportation emissions are affected by our
choice of vehicles for transport and the fuel economy of our cars and even the distances traveled
following slides show ways that individuals like average citizens can decrease the greenhouse
gas emissions and it indicates the number of kilograms of carbon dioxide that each action
could save annually they might seem trivial in comparison of the scope of the problem
but when they're multiplied by more than 320 million people in the US the savings then can
become significant driving energy efficient vehicles carpooling recycling walking instead
of driving buying higher efficiency appliances buying food and other products with reusable
or recyclable packaging or reduced packaging using push mowers instead of power mode mowers
planting shade trees around the home to decrease energy consumption and to remove carbon dioxide
by photosynthesis as an added bonus having an effect on industrial commercial and agricultural
sectors is difficult for anyone individual changes in these areas will instead take leadership
from those policymakers who are committed to reducing emissions making these changes
requires that our leaders and all of us understand that even though the implications of and solutions
to global warming may be open to debate the fact that it is occurring at an unprecedented
rate is not open to debate the evidence the data shows it is occurring especially with
the problem of the speed at which things are changing again be sure to review the learning
outcomes for the chapter.